thank you
well good morning welcome to early
morning sessions I'm glad all of you are
here hope you had loads of coffee I'll
make sure that I keep you awake
these are some of the URLs you actually
might want to keep it open on your tab
I had put instructions in the schedule
to have your laptop set up if you really
wanted to follow along
I would recommend not to do it now
because you're going to be spending some
time and given that we have we have a
big group over here everybody
downloading and installing on the laptop
could be a diversion so I really want to
concentrate on on the workshop today I'm
going to walk through
the introduction and I'll walk through
this walk through the notebooks myself
and since this is something that you can
actually take home with you if you need
sleeping aids tonight you can probably
use that as a tutorials it'll actually
help you
so let's get started again welcome this
is going to be a session about
introduction to Rey for distributed
computing and machine learning using
python basically we had Pi data actually
makes sense to do that
and I just want to get to know
what your background is and where you're
from so I can sort of understand and
calibrate the presentation so how many
of you actually
um have heard about rape
good you guys can go home then
how many of you are using Ray
good that you can stay
how many of you consider yourself data
scientist
I mean if you consider yourself machine
learning
how many you consider jumping on the
bandwagon to be model
foundational builders
okay
and I'm going to ask you a
tongue-in-check question how many of you
are python experts here
it's like going to a Catholic church and
asking is a proper Catholic you know
well welcome thank you very much
my name is Jules damji I am a lead
developer Advocate at any skill part of
the rate team very much embedded in the
engineering team and prior to that I was
a senior developer at
um at databricks where I spent about
six years contributing to Apache spark
and and ammo flow and then prior to that
I was at hortonworks doing very much the
same thing and then prior that I held
many software engineering positions that
some of the notable companies so I was
very fortunate I was very very pleased
to be at the right time at the right
moment to really see the evolution of
this
fourth Evolution we're actually having
called foundational models so I think I
think there's actually great to be part
of it just been very fortunate to be
part of this particular Journey
who do I work for I work for a company
called any scale and we were the
original creators of Ray and Ray sort of
emerged from Berkeley's rice lab which
was a successor to the amp lab and where
Spark was born
tachyon was born mesos was born a cafe
was born so these were sort of the what
I would call the Berkeley's Innovation
Labs where they were very tied much of
the industry and these were the open
source projects that that were born and
what do we do you know what is evolution
well we provide you the unified platform
to deploy and manage your scalable
python applications and why do we do
that our mission really is to make sure
that scaling is today a necessity it's
not an exception and we want to make
sure that anybody in this particular
room with a python programmer can
actually take advantage of that it used
to be the case in the early days where
you actually had to be a distributed
machine learning or distributed software
developer to know the internals of that
we wanted to sort of be abstracted away
and make that a possibility for everyone
because scaling is is a necessity in
scaling is difficult
so here's the agenda what I'm going to
cover today give you sort of an
intuition of why and what Ray is and
rates ecosystem
and then we'll drop down into
re-architecture and components and what
are some of the
individual record design scaling
patterns that actually make this
actually possible and you can't be at a
conference today and not talk about
foundational models and not talk about
generative Ai and I just wanted to sort
of touch on just a little diversion
about how rare fits into the generative
Ai and we just consider large language
models just one of the workloads that
you can actually use to Ray and one of
the interesting bit about that the
companies who build this foundational
models such as coherent and open AI they
use Rey initially to to train and tune
these models and then we'll go in a
class for modules one uh the rest of
them I'm gonna make have you do extra
calculate because we don't have the time
this is normally like a full day course
okay
so why Ray I think they are when when
when the original researchers were
working on this particular project at
Rice lab
they were quite prescient about sort of
thinking about three industry trends
that were sort of dominating at that
particular time we're talking about 2016
to 17 and this was prior to to spark
which was about 10 years earlier and
they realized that machine learning is
pervasive it's going to be perversive
and and it's true today ml is everywhere
right it's on your laptop it's in the
industry it's in robotics it's in health
science all over the place it's a
pervasive thing and larger and larger
compute infrastructure is actually
needed to build large language models or
or models today are getting larger so
you need a lot of compute power and that
necessitates that that if you're going
to be doing machine learning at a large
scale
distributed computing became a necessity
it wasn't you know it was an exception
in the older days you know you use HPC
you use MPI to write and you really had
to be very
expert in the able to write this due to
the application today it is a necessity
and if something is actually in a
necessity and it's going to be
ubiquitous as as machine learning is
today you have to make sure that you can
actually use it easily and I would
contend that python because you're here
today is the default language right for
machine learning if you look at all the
Frameworks out today all of them
actually have python bindings there
might be implemented in C plus that
might be implemented in C but they do
have python bindings as a first class
Citizen and that is the default language
so those were the three primary sort of
pillars or foundational ideas that
actually draw into the evolution of Rey
at that time
now we are blessed with what I would
call the blessings of scale now if you
look at the chart you know on on the far
left hand side and how actually the the
models have evolved today your laptop
can do anywhere from 10 billion to maybe
100 million instructions per second
floating Point instruction second
but when you come to building large
models a lot of machine learning both
statistics traditional statistical
models and today's you know Foundation
models we are talking about exponential
way in which you actually need that but
these blessings of scale kind of also
introduce another problem which we call
supply and demand
now we know that Moore's Law is dead
rest in peace he passed away last week
um and we can see that the GPU so have
somehow was meeting some of that
particular demands and the hardware
accelerators like a TPU kind of met that
particular demand but if you look at the
linear scale in which the the the the
the the the compute power is actually
needed it's about 35x every month and
there's a huge gap right there's a huge
gap between what the today's
accelerators can provide you and what
the demands of this particular models
are and we contend that the only way you
can actually do that if you actually go
distribute it right you only have to to
distribute otherwise you just can't do
it you have to go across the entire
cluster
and the third one was the pi data
ecosystem right you can actually see
some of you actually have worked with
this particular libraries you're working
with these libraries and these are the
sort of the traditional libraries that
you actually use to do your you know
your your number crunching or your data
Transformations and the library is on
the right hand side all their python
Bindings that allow you to do machine
learning both statistical and deep
learning as well so that was sort of the
third Trend that people actually saw
going
so I've talked about why Ray right what
was the foundation what was the
philosophical reason of of doing that
and we're actually beginning to see the
the massive adoption rate today for
doing machine learning at scale
so I'm gonna switch about the wood
history right
what is Ray I'll talk about why Ray and
what is Ray and I think one thing I want
you to take away from this presentation
if not anything else it's a simple
general purpose library for doing
distributed computing
and it comes out of the box with three
kinds of abstractions that we're going
to talk about today they're going to
have workshops on and the library is
actually built on top of that for you to
be able to do scale your machine
learning workloads now when I talk about
machine learning work tools what am I
talking about I'm talking about data
ingestion data transformation I'm
talking about doing batches and
distributing your data across workers in
the cluster where they can actually do
training so there's a library for that
we're talking about batch inference or
or hyper parameter tuning is another big
Library tune that comes out of the box
but it's actually built on the record
Primitives we're talking about
reinforcement learning which is an
important part today in both building
Foundation models but also in the gaming
industry and in other areas where you're
actually solving and optimizing problem
and you're learning as you actually go
along and the good thing is it actually
runs on your laptop is so today you're
going to be running running on your
laptop it runs on any of the public
Cloud they actually have it's open
source you can run it on premise and you
can run on kubernetes
but another way to locate it is layered
kicker functionality you know what I
mean by layer cable functionality right
at the bottom you actually have all the
clouds that you can actually run on and
then one level above is the rare core
and we're going to talk about what Ray
core is today
and Ray core sort of provides you these
abstractions to allow you to write your
python application convert them into
either tasks which are stateless
functions or actors which are stateful
actors and then the objects is a shared
memory that is across the cluster and
we'll get into that
and this is sort of the ray core on
which these libraries are built right so
if you go one level above we have this
thing called Ray air which is a unified
toolkit that allows you to build this ml
applications so you can do data training
transformation you can do train you can
do tune serving our lib and if you don't
care about this thing right if you're
not a machine learning programmer let's
say a physicist or you are a geologist
or you're a climate climatologist we
have one in the room
um who wants to scale the python
applications to do numerical
computations you can use Python tasks to
do that so it sort of so two purposes
you can actually use rate to build your
machine learning libraries using the the
existing libraries and they're very work
very cohesively or you can just use Ray
to do other distributed tasks and just
to give you this architecture diagram in
the rare air I'm talking about has got
all these different Integrations that we
actually have that allows you to do end
to end so for Ray data you can use any
of these libraries that actually are
integrated with Ray
for training we have Integrations with
pie chart xgboost any of the popular
library that you actually are using
today to build both your statistical or
traditional model or also using uh deep
learning models as well and if you're
doing hyper parameter tuning we have a
tuning library but you can actually
provide your schedulers you can provide
your search algorithms you can provide
any of the third-party algorithms that
are provided by this library that you
can actually work with tune so if you're
doing a massive hyper parameter tuning
and let's say you want to use Asha
scheduler and you want to use early
stopping and you want to provide a
search grid on which you can do that you
can do that with Ray tune this is sort
of the advanced one and if you do
experiment in tracking which is an
important part if you're building
machine learning models today you need
to track exactly how what parameters you
use all the artifacts you actually
created and so we have Integrations with
that we don't provide that as part of
the rape but we provide Integrations you
can actually do that
and so on and so forth down the line and
these are sort of very scalable because
they run on top of rates so you can
actually scale them across so that sort
of is is the whole idea behind it the
very high level you know what Ray is all
about
now I'm going to go down a little into
what the ray architecture is because I
think it's important for you to
understand behind the scenes how things
actually laid out
right now if you look at this this
architecture it's no different from any
other Computing distributed company that
you have you know such as dasco such as
Apache spark the idea is that you're
going to have workers and the workers
will be executing some job on the top of
that but there's something quite unique
about about this particular Anatomy is
that the headphone actually has the
driver and the worker and the worker can
be any python process that's bound to a
CPU so if you have eight CPUs you can
have eight python works that's working
there is a rail at which actually has
two threads one is a scheduler another
one is an object store and scheduler is
responsible for managing and scheduling
tasks and actors and making sure that
that your tasks are scheduled at to a
particular node where you actually have
enough resources and the object store is
a shared memory uh Object Store which is
built on top of Apache plasma and the
object store allows you to store any
objects that you actually don't want to
check greater than 100 kilobytes so you
can share this object store across you
actually have a shared memory store that
goes across and then when objects are
created they actually put in the object
store if you have processors running on
the same worker or any workers running
on on the same particular work node they
can get the objects to zero copy so
you're not copying it there's no IPC
going on between processes they just use
the shared memory and that's something
quite unique about that none of the
other distributed systems have that you
have a distributed schedule you don't
have a a main scheduler there's any of
the raillets can actually schedule
yourself so you have a distributed
schedule you have an out distributed
object store where you can actually
share any objects that you actually put
in and then there's a global store that
has think of it as it's a meta
information about
what processes are anywhere what tasks
are running where what are the resources
what are the GPU resources anytime when
when raillet wants to schedule something
it consults the object store and
periodically every 10 milliseconds the
object so broadcast
the the current state of of all the
resources how many Hardware resources I
have how many gpus I have and if a new
if a new worker comes in it register
itself with the global object store and
then actually educated broadcast so the
rail at any point has an idea of what is
my resource across the entire cluster
and this all happens behind the scene
you don't have to worry about it Ray
sort of takes care of that
so that's the anatomy of the cluster and
now as I want to get into some of the
design patterns that Ray supports and
you probably have seen those design
patterns in other programming language
and what's so unique about about that
with Ray and how it actually projects or
translates that into apis
so some of you probably have heard about
this design patterns have you anybody
who read this particular book
right so design patterns were introduced
in our Consciousness
um by this gang of four right and they
sort of introduced this this high level
concept of how design patterns are used
in high programming languages and in Rey
you actually have three design patterns
that that we share and we Implement you
know one is the parallel Ray tasks and
rate tasks are nothing but any python
function that you have you can convert
that into a distributed setting and that
allows it to run cluster across it
allows you to run tasks across the
cluster and that can actually scale and
these are stateless right which means
that there's no statement in
the second thing I talked about is the
array object as Futures and Futures are
something you probably have come across
if you're using Scala or if you're using
um today's python features as something
that materialize uh later on down down
down the the time of your machine of
your application and they can be fetched
when they actually materialize and those
are normally blocking holes and this
ability to do asynchronously allows you
to paralyze stuff so the combination of
parallel rate tasks and the ability for
the tasks or access to create these
features as objects that that you they
might get might return they are stored
in the object store so we can just
schedule something it will go and do the
tasks when the um when the tasks are
ready you can actually go and fetch them
and then reactors just extend parallel
Tower so if you have a particular python
class that you have and you want to make
that into a stateful service or a micro
service you can use reactors and that
allows you to do message passing between
actors or between tasks and actors and
these three are the fundamental
abstractions that are the core on which
all the other libraries actually build
and these are sort of the solid core you
know you don't have to worry about
scheduling you don't have a memory
management all that's actually taken
care by array itself you just write your
functions or write your your python code
using these abstractions and we'll see
some of that in the workshop
and there's some links over here by the
way the slides are in the GitHub there
is a slide directory if you go to the
directory there is a pi data Seattle
directory you can always get to the
slides if you want to follow along
now some of the scaling design patterns
which are very common that you actually
have either worked with or you have we
have encountered are what we call
scaling design pattern one is what we
call different data same function right
this is very common for your machine
learning workflows such as batch
training and inference what you're doing
is you're actually taking a large data
set that you actually have when you're
creating into shards and you're using
the same function or the same model or a
copy of a model which is across the
cluster and you're predicting it or
you're doing inferencing or you're
you're your batch inference different
data same function right A variation of
that is you're using the same data we're
using different functions so let's say
you actually want to train two or three
models you know you want to do a linear
linear regression you want to do XC
boost anymore decision Tree on the same
data but you want to use different hyper
parameters to to make sure that you can
train those different models so we're
here using the same data you're training
three different algorithms or three
different functions and you're getting
the end result at the back and you're
picking the best one
and the batch training is no different
right batch training is that you
actually want to use different data but
the same sort of function so when you do
distributed training you want to take
the data you want to Shard it and you
want to give it to the same model to the
same function of your objective function
to do the training so this is sort of at
a high level what it is and we'll go
through some of the exercises that are
in the workshop so those are sort of the
design scaling patterns I talk about now
how does that translate into the apis I
talked about the three design patterns I
talked about how do they translate in
the python code so you have a python
function just you know some random
function I have a class and then I have
some numpy assignments that I want to
now convert that into its Ray equivalent
and all I need is I just put the
decorator core radar remote
and then what radar remote does or at
least with the driver does whatever this
thing is is doing the ray light will
actually schedule this particular task
on any one of the nodes that you
actually have
all right simple as that you don't
really remember the IP address you don't
have to worry about where the ray
cluster is you don't have to worry about
the way the record worker knowed it
um you can just do that by doing radar
remote the second bit is I talk about
stateful functions is where you actually
take a class that you actually have and
you want to maintain a particular state
and you just do the same thing you
decorate that we did a remote and that
converts that into a distributed service
or a distributed Object Store running on
each and every node now each and every
instance of a reactor you create will
will have a different instance running
right one instant would be scheduled on
one note if you create another instant
there'll be a schedule on the third note
and so on and so forth
and then finally
if you have
data that you actually want to store and
distribute as distributed object stores
and other workers in the cluster can get
access to it all you do is you use these
very simple apis array put and reg get
and then these will be somehow stored
into a particular array object node with
that particular data on it and then any
worker running on that particular node
can actually use row.get
if the object a and if object a is
created on node a but there is a process
running a node B that requires node a
then the primary copy is copied over and
then once that you actually pretty much
will have it across so there's an
initial
um
overhead of coping it over it but once
you actually have that you'll have
shared it across so those are sort of
the Ray apis I talked about any
questions
yes
the actual is an instance of the class
right so when you actually create an
actor you're saying this is my template
right so when I you'll see how we
actually create an instance so when I'm
doing a the cluster remote see this code
over here cluster I'm creating an
instance of that and then when I want to
invoke any of its methods that I have
which is this method I just invoke
the method name and then I pass the
arguments right if I'm in the
construction arguments that I want I
just provide that in this particular
call and it will go ahead and initiate
that with the Constructor so that's a
simple example but we'll see that in the
workshop
yeah
so
in the earliest like you said that the
objects are kept on a shared menu
thank you
yeah so
um good question how does this actually
get shared in the memory let's say this
particular object
gets placed on node a
right and there's a task that's running
on node a it'll be able to use that
object right away there's another task B
running on node a you'll be able to get
that through zero copy because processes
share share shared memory so you don't
have to copy into processing now let's
say there's a Class C or task C which is
running on node B and it needs a
reference to a somehow you know you you
need that particular dog you actually
send it a reference and and and this
task we say well where this particular
node I'm going to find out from from GCS
where this particular node and then it
will ask the rail led to go and copy it
so this particular slide that I had with
the drelet knows exactly where they
reference it it's going to copy it over
and now this is a secondary copy that I
have
right and once that is out of scope this
will go away the primary copy will
remain and so we have a distributed
reference counting and then all the
references are gone
yes we are coping yeah you actually
we're using grpc to actually copy data
and once it's over here then then it's
stored in the shared memory
thank you
so just just to give you a sort of
illustration what actually happens is
that when you actually create a
particular task you can provide the the
resources that you actually want so here
I said I want to reserve two CPUs for
this because all I'm doing is a plus b
no pun intended but you know I'm just
giving an illustration over here that I
need two CPUs for that particular that
and then what I have is now this is
going to be
scheduled on any one of the worker nodes
that actually has two CPUs result and
it'll start executing that so that's how
that's how this particular remote
function is done when it does a plus b
Returns what happens over here is that
it will return right away
asynchronously and it will give you an
object reference and then the object
reference can actually be fetched to get
the result A and B when it materializes
right asynchronously so that's the great
thing about tasks is that you can create
thousands of tasks and all of them will
be scheduled right away and then it'll
start executing and when they when
they're finished they will actually put
their objects in real object store and
then you can actually have an ability
you know in a weight while loop to
actually go and fetch those things
in a similar manner a reactor actually
has the ability to to specify the same
thing our phone number gpus and I want
this particular actor to be
um
distributed across hosts that actually
have four gpus so when I request the
four gpus what happens at this point is
that the radius Ray let schedulers say
okay
I don't have full resources
so let me
broadcast that the gcp to find out which
Ray LED actually has four gpus and I'm
going to get a list from that and then
one that lease I get that particular
disk the ray light will actually
schedule now that particular remote that
particular host actor to be scheduled on
that particular host so all these things
actually happening behind we really
don't have to worry about it but I just
wanted to give you an intuition of what
happens under the hood
okay let's look at some code right here
we actually have a function that I'm
taking
um
which just takes in a file and then
returns a numpy array of that and then I
have a function called add that actually
takes two references to it two values or
whatever that is
and then computes the addition of those
and then I'm doing a ray.get so what's
happening over here well
when radar remote is scheduled it's
going to read that particular file and
it will convert that into a numpy it
will return a reference
right it's not written actually data is
just returning a reference
um and then Ed radar takes two arguments
A and B and I'm going to add those to
numpy arrays and I'm going to return the
value and I'm not going to return the
actual value but I'm going to return a
reference to it an object or future
so when I do read.ery.remote I'm getting
a reference to it right away right it's
not going to read the file that's going
to start reading the file but what you
would get is is an object reference and
the same thing with file number two and
now note the difference over here is
that I'm not sending the actual values
of the file that's actually read what
I'm sending over here is the object
reference that was actually returned by
these two calls for me and then I'm just
sending the references over here now
when I send the object reference what
this particular array n is going to do
is that oh I've got an object reference
it's not actually available so I'm going
to de-references I'm going to go find
out where this object reference is and
if you look at the object reference we
have an encoded value how it's actually
done and it's going to get the value of
those numpy arrays after you've read
from the file and return you and then
when I get the value back the addition
note that I'm doing array.get
all right now Ray don't get at this time
is a blocking call because I don't know
whether the value returned by this has
already materialize and I don't know the
value written by ID in ide1 a bow has
already been materialized because it's
the file that's actually reading so this
is sort of one of The Blocking codes
but what happens over here is that these
can be scheduled right away and you get
references back and you just continue
doing that so that's one of the uh sort
of fine bits about that yeah
it will start reading it but you read it
asynchronously right what happens over
here the the read part of that is is is
is is scheduled by the redlet and and
you'll just get a reference back right
so this is
no it doesn't wait it just it yeah you
just get the reference right away right
it'll be like within one millisecond
boom you got the reference right and
then you can do a radar get on it and
you'll see you'll see that it's blocking
but if it's ready you'll be able to get
the data
sir
yeah yeah
yeah I mean radar get is just saying
that is it materialized if it is already
materializing the object store boom
return me the value right
so you're not obliged to call radar to
get right away you can call it later
down the line as you're going you're
doing other stuff but this is all
happening in the background
asynchronously and that's the beauty of
it because you can create all these
tasks and later on you know get the
values as they are needed
something very similar with with class
actor is that you actually just say for
this particular array remote I want a
counter it to have one GPU and then you
write those particular methods and you
create an instance of c and then go
ahead and and increment uh any of the
methods that you have and the way you
increment the way you invoke its method
is just use the function name I mean the
instant just like you do that in in
Python you have an object you create the
method name but over here we just have
the suffix code remote and then have any
arguments do that
the same thing over here in both cases
always return a reference right you
always have to do a radar Gap
and this is this is what we were talking
about is that when this is actually
happens I have readout array that's
actually reading a file and it's going
to return an ID reference right away
the other
um the other Ray re the other read array
could be a schedule on another note and
this guy's going to return a reference
so there's this Dynamic graph it's
actually building and then we're
actually adding those two numbers and
then returning the value of the
particular reference and then finally
we're doing array.get
you don't know how big that file is in
fact right
um is under a hood raised figuring out
to distribute that over a memory of
yeah yeah there's a library called radar
data I mean you actually have let's say
10 gigabyte file sitting on sitting on
S3 what it's going to do is going to
block it's going to read blocks of that
and and and Shard it across across the
red cluster and then return you uh those
particular blocks and we will see some
of the particular example I hope we have
enough time I'm going to run through
this slides very quick and then the
object store that I talked about is this
illustration of what an object store is
and it has a shared memory Object Store
and any of these worker processes on
which a tasks are scheduled or the
actors are scheduled they can access any
of the objects which have been created
by that and this is all zero copy so I'm
not doing inter-process copy now it's
not inconsiderable that that sometimes
you know your object store has a limited
capacity and you're putting in a lot of
lumpy areas you're putting a lot of
images in there and you'll run out of
you'll run out of shared memory and
they'll spill to the disk
right and you can specify with that
particular disk is whether you want it
on S3 or whether you want an EBS storage
or whatever high performance or NFS file
system you actually have mounted in the
cluster that can be actually stored and
then when it's actually stored it's
actually noted in the GCS that this
particular object of your reference that
you have
used to exist on node a but now it's
stored in the in the disk and that's how
you actually get that and then this is
some sort of simulation of how sort of
shared memory actually works
um anybody actually has worked with
shared memory
okay right I mean this was already a
common way of how Unix shared uh data
you know you just create this slash Dev
slash share memory you know provide that
and then you can you can just write
write stuff to it and this is based on a
Apache plasma which is very efficient
and the calls to it are very simple to
get do a put do a weight and you're done
okay and just to give you an
illustration this is actually what's
happening and I have a radar remote
function that I have scheduled so that
might be executed in node two then I'm
doing another remote function so that
function is going to be uh
executed or scheduled on that particular
note because Ray actually has an idea of
data Affinity so if if if f is actually
referencing a data that I know is
actually stored over there the relate is
smart enough to actually schedule it
over there so I don't have to do a copy
across the node
and this is actually what happens over
here the G is going to schedule over
here now it has access to both the data
so that's sort of what's Happening
behind the scene
okay so why would you actually use Rey
I'm going to sort of give you and I just
want to give you a quick high level
before we actually get into the uh the
workshops you can use rare to build
libraries we actually use that to build
our array of runtime that I talked about
in the slide you can use Ray to to to
build other distributed Frameworks that
you actually hear so for example we have
a version of XC boost Ray which you can
actually do that XC boost today allows
you to do distributed compute but on a
single node
right you can actually take eight chords
that you actually have and you can
distribute your your objective function
on that or your or your algorithm on it
and it will it will distribute it across
but what about if you actually want it
across the cluster so you know we have
wrapper on that same thing with
scikitlan like joblib allows you to do
that locally but now you can actually do
it across
um Ray actually also you can write
multi-processors pool we actually have
multi-processor pool then Ray so these
are all the ray patterns that allows you
to build those things what are some of
the other things that people actually
use Ray for you know you can use that
for monitoring experimenting you know
people actually have integrated array
with that and then finally you know we
have all these Integrations all these
companies are actually using array to
build their own platform
right because if we provide you the
abstraction you can actually build
additional uh your own existing platform
they actually have we have integration
hugging phase and Pi torch and Alpine
all those things so that's what people
actually using Ray for
now
it behooves me not to talk about Rey and
not talk about
large language models because I think we
have sort of Interest the Zeiss guys of
this foundational shift
and
luckily
um Ray is just there at the right time
so what is the current state of the
world with respect to foundational
models so you got this big tech
companies right you got cohere you got
open AI you got intro Pig you got
hugging phase stability eye every day
there's new coming these are also the
people who actually have deep resources
they have the Deep engineering expertise
they have lots of money
and they can actually use the compute
power to build foundational model from
scratch right and
fortunately when they were when when we
had our race Summit last year Greg
Brockman who was one of the founders of
of cohere of open AI
uh revealed to us publicly that they
were looking at some distributed
Frameworks to figure out how they can
actually train GPT and how they could
actually train
um
chat GPT and then how they can actually
use the reinforcement human feedback and
they tried many Frameworks and didn't
work scaling just didn't work and they
decided to go with Ray because it gave
them the Primitives to actually do that
so those models were actually built
using red but what about if you and me
want to use language models what do you
do right
we mere mortals actually have two
choices or three choices you know we can
download some of the model from the
hugging phase
right they have pretend weights and then
we can fine tune that with our data they
actually want to do either summarization
or we wanted we want to do some q a
instruction set for that and then we can
actually do serve and inference but all
these three things that we can actually
do mere mortals actually has some
challenges that we have to overcome you
know one thing is that scaling can be
directly costly because you want to
start fine-tuning this particular models
even if there are six billion parameters
or 175 billion parameters you need you
need clusters to actually scale and
distribute your training so you can go
with you know you can go with sport
instances but sport incidents can
disappear
right and if they disappear you can lose
some of the state so you have to have a
framework that allows you to actually
take control and fall back or or or or
has the ability to recover from those
things and then most of the time if
you're actually using both hardware and
and and CPU and GPU resources sometimes
you might have a a an ideal GPU just
sitting there because your CPU is doing
some computation and it's waiting for a
data to do this GPU inference so you
have to have a framework that can
can can minimize the ideal time and you
can do pipelining things as soon as the
data is available for one it can be fed
into GPU to do that so you actually have
to have the ability to do that the other
thing that models don't exist in
isolation
right if you actually build a particular
model there'll be ensembles of model
right you might have a model that's just
doing a prediction and they might take
the prediction and feed it into into one
of the classifiers and the classifier
might give it uh data to that each of
this separate models which are built as
a single unit of execution might need
different different
um ways you can actually scale it right
so these replicas that you actually
might create they have to have the
ability to scale automatically so you
have to worry about those things because
there might be one model that's taking a
lot of traffic and you won't be able to
scale it and scale down and then finally
you know when you're doing fine tuning
you know there's a lot of tweaks that
you will actually make do you want to do
distributed training and you also want
to change some of the hyper parameter
tuning so you can actually get the best
um uh pre-trained model and fine-tune
that so these are some of the challenge
for beer models and
what Ray allows you to do and one of the
one of the things that we actually done
is that we try to simplify the
orchestration by making sure that the
sport instances when they fail over we
actually meant to understand you can
recover from it the ability for you to
actually do inference referencing and
scale it independently right so has the
ability for you to scale independent uh
replicas and then training you know
training in tuning Ray train can has all
the wrappers around pytorch and and and
in tensorflow and XC boost to be able to
do that so if you're writing all this
boiler clothes to do DDP with pytorch
you don't have to do that you just use
the raid Pi torch trainer and underneath
it will actually do all the all the
Boiler code for that so the way we
actually use pie torch is if you're
doing data data distributed data
parallel we create the process groups
and then underneath the python processes
do the radiance synchronization so all
that code you don't have to worry about
it that's that's done for you
and we're beginning to see two emerging
Stacks in the open source Community
today
you've got people who actually want to
be a foundation models from the scratch
they can use Jacks for it they can use
Alpha that allows you to do modal
parallelism because if you're building
you know create a building parameters
you actually need to be able to do to
build models in apparel or do their
inferences at the same time and they're
using rate for the orchestration for
both GPU and CPU and then they can
actually compile some of the alpha code
that you actually have and then you can
actually run that on a GPU accelerator
so these are the people actually want to
build open source from scratch these are
all open source stack you cannot use the
thing you have to pay for is obviously
this thing over here because that can be
here costly
the other stack we actually see you
already have a pre-trained model and all
you want to do is just a little bit of
tuning a little bit of training so you
you download the hugging face model you
can use the deep deep speed accelerator
that we actually have integrated with
that and you can use a pytorch framework
and then use Ray for acceleration and
then you can use any GPU that you
actually want that your Hardware that
your GPU supports right so this is
building from scratch this is taking
existing stack that you have and then
using all open source that you actually
have so that's essentially
what we talk about and what we have done
to verify that to give you a social
proof to give you guidance we have
created a half a dozen blogs that
actually tell you how you can actually
use array for all these things so if you
go to any scale goal you have a series
of this particular blog that give you
the notebook that actually gives you
exactly how to do it and this is a
validation for us to say you know open
source is here right you could actually
work with the proprietary stuff but this
is also good that you can actually use
and these are the companies who are
actually using Ray and we actually have
a specific talk that you actually want
to attend on Friday which will go more
detail into how llm is actually used and
we're going to train a flan T5 model to
see how you can actually do that okay so
takeaways
um distributed company is a necessity
why because ml is very pervasive our
vision is to make sure that that it's
actually easy for anybody to actually
use it and lay libraries allow you to
scale your machine learning workloads
and Ray offers a compute substrata for
generic workloads okay we have a summit
coming up anybody attended Ray Summit
before
okay we have a rare Summit coming up on
on September in San Francisco a good
reason to get out of Northwest and come
down to sunny California uh September
the 15th through 18th I believe when we
have a full day of training so
guys from Denmark you guys can come over
okay let's go to the code now any
questions before I get into the workshop
yeah so when you're running when you're
eating rayon kubernetes there is a
cubery operator that allows you to to do
that
right so there's a cubery operator that
that can that can scale your your pods
actually want so if you're running on
kubernetes with Ray you use the cubery
operator to do the orchestration
and if you're using Reserve to to
scale the replicas there is a race of
operator that does that so yeah we work
with Cube Rivers that's why so you can
actually run on kubernetes
with with the cubery operator and that
was a community contribution from
Microsoft and and I believe Google and
and any skill
yes
I can't hear you
spark and in maybe in particular you
mentioned that XG boost is implemented
there's an accident implementation for
array there's also one for sparse
yeah a good question I think there's
certain workloads which which are very
good for spark right so if I was doing
say
ETL and Eda I wouldn't use Ray because
Ray is not equipped for that if there
are certain batch inferences you're
doing for
um at a massive scale then Ray accepts
that we actually have some performance
numbers which are going to come out next
week we've written pretty good brokes
you actually see how we have compared
both Ray Apache spark Ray and and
sagemaker to do batch inference at scale
and then give you the the performance
number the other you know the other
workloads like data transformation and
all that actually that does vary right
so if you're using pandas if you're
using pie pandas you can use particular
spark but today you have modern which is
distributed Panda so you can actually
use Modern Monterey right so the owl
there's uh differences you actually
think about that and the other problem
is you now actually have two different
clusters you got a spark cluster and you
got a red cluster right I look at it
this way and this is you know I'm I'm a
big fan of sparking because I worked
there for saying it and wrote a book
once bar I look at it this way is that
they're very complementary
you know the the spark does good things
with certain things and I believe that
the Journey of of a machine learning
data scientist ends where the the
Journey of the data engineer ends so
once your ETL is done once your data is
cleansed everything is ready in in the
case of actually bootstructured data
sitting on the table in S3 or or in a
Delta Lake you can now hand it off to to
to the ray to be able to do that
training because now you already have
the trainer you might use Last Mile
transformations
right where you might want to you know
change the image or you might want to do
some do some some scaling of the image
those can be done with Ray data that
allows you uh has the preprocessors that
run with the training Loop so yes they
are all those things I don't have the
numbers but next week we might have
numbers in one particular workload
I don't have one for the XC boost
um can you can you talk to me I might
have something in documentation that we
actually did some numbers but it's no
comparison we just saw some numbers on
Ray where they're more about how XE
boost on One Core obviously one six core
obviously what are course distributed
but now we haven't done those
comparisons
because one of the things that when you
run distributed training on on Apache
spark you use horror wood on top of that
right
because you have to use horrible to do
the distributed training and that allows
that that's an additional uh layer that
you actually put here to take into
account
any other question
okay how many of you are successful to
put
[Music]
um
spark not Sparks hooray say this all
happens when you work for company for
too long you can't get the things out of
your head
um how many of you put Ray on your on
your laptop
okay this is optional I mean I just
wanted people to somehow you can follow
along by just going to the particular
notebook that you actually have so these
actually had three modules we're not
going to cover all of them I'll try to
cover at least the first three if I have
the time we have about 45 minutes so
let's go into into the first notebook
okay I can see the screen
okay so you've seen this particular
slide all I'm actually doing is is
showing you how you can actually take an
existing Ray application that you
actually have which is serially in
Python and then convert that into into a
parallel execution and the task of
parallelism pattern is very simple you
can actually either have one worker
that's executing all these particular
tasks or you can actually have array
schedule all this tasks on different
workers and now you actually think
executing parallel so this is the
parallel execution versus versus serial
execution and we'll get some of the
examples of that and the way you uh the
way you actually do that is is if you
actually have a function once you
actually
put the ray decorator on that you can
actually use the the function
name.remote to be able to just send
arguments to that to to execute remotely
so we're going to do something very
simple and generate the the lazy uh
Apache I mean uh Fibonacci series so I
have about 10 million
100 000 numbers that I want to create in
the Fibonacci Theory and I'm just going
to create this particularly generic
python function that is going to take my
Fibonacci number and then calculate
those Fibonacci series and then return
me the length I'd only written all the
numbers because it's just going to be
too big but I'm just going to return the
length which is going to be 100 000. and
then I have a remote function which all
I'm doing is I'm just decorating that
particular function so that I want to
now run it remotely
so we're going to do that and I want to
find out how many CPUs do I have so I
can create that many
tasks separately so I have 10 of those
right so that gives me train and then
I'm going to have another function as I
say run this locally right and then this
particular code I'm just using
um comprehension to go ahead and create
10 tasks serially each of these are
going to compute you know Fibonacci
series for 10 000. this is just an
illustration to see how long it actually
takes running sequentially in parallel
so let's run this in local mode and then
time it and you'll actually see that it
took about one
1.9 seconds to do 10 tasks to compute
all the Fibonacci series for that
so now let's actually do that for Ray
cluster did I actually start the cluster
I normally you know whenever I'm doing
notebooks I go ahead and sort of restart
the the cluster on my on my laptops I
start everything from scratch
and there is a dashboard that actually
comes with that and we'll get into that
in a minute it actually shows you the
metrics and all that all right so we did
that serially and what about we actually
do that run remote in a distributed
manner and so when we when you do a run
remote what am I doing over here
so the Run remote is doing exactly the
same thing but the only difference over
here is that I'm executing 10 different
tasks remotely
and each of them will get 10 000 numbers
and it will execute in parallel and then
I'll get my results back as as the
object reference so that's what actually
is happening over here
so we're going to run that
you can say 25 milliseconds right now
the difference between
the wool time over here and the wall
time over there you say well why there
is a difference between those two this
particular old time takes into account
that remember you're actually doing
array.get which is a blocking call right
and that's where the additional time is
but you can say there's a significant
difference in something executing
serially and something executing using
Ray
now for exercises normally we when I
have this all-day Workshop you know we
we break at this point and you guys
start doing the exercises but I have
Solutions over there so you can actually
look at that tonight if you actually
want let's do something else let's do
something interesting let's see if we
can actually compute the the value of pi
using the same mechanism using serially
and then using in parallel and the way
we actually compute using Monte Carlo
simulations is that we try to to get as
many spots or in many data points
between this one by one square and the
concentric Circle if they're inside then
we can actually do that and we take a
ratio of that and then compute what the
pi is and so we're going to take again
10 tasks because we have I have 10 CPUs
if you have 20 CPUs you can actually do
20 CPUs
I'm going to cook it about 10 million
data points so I want to you know as
many data points as I have I probably
have a better approximation of Pi
and then so my total number of samples
is going to be my total number of tasks
I'm going to run times times the number
of number of data points
and then I'm going to use this
particular function to determine if the
data point random data point between -1
and 1 falls into that particular Circle
and if it does then I just compute that
and if it doesn't then then I go
I go home
right
so let's do that run serially and again
seriously I'm doing the same thing we're
actually using a comprehension list to
go ahead and and create 10 tasks
serially and each task
I'll just assign a task ID so I know
this is Task one task 2 and then we're
sending the same sample size up to the
serial and we're going to go ahead and
do that
and likewise
um for distributed we are just going to
put
a rear decorate on top of that and then
return an object and an object over here
is is whatever is returned by by the the
sampling function
and the Run distributed does couple of
things here right first first it
actually does is does the same thing as
the serial one in a comprehension list
and then I'm just putting array.get
around it now notice that I'm actually
doing array.get after all of them have
been executed if I put radar to get
inside what do you think will happen
if a block on each and every call right
so you'll just wait for it to finish
whereas over here I'm saying go ahead
and schedule all those things and when
you're done with it
when I get back my object reference
because what this will happen is that it
will go in and schedule all these 10
tasks remotely and return me the object
reference right away and then I'll just
do rate.get and when I do radar get I'll
get the sample of that and I just took
the sum of all those and I'll find out
so the way we cook it at the pie
is to take a ratio of those things and
now let's run this
cerealing so when we run this serially
you know you can see that the task ID
so the first sample task ID took about
what
similarly seven million of those
so these are all the data points that
fell into that particular particular
inscribed Circle within the square
and this is all actually happening
serially and you'll see a difference
between the parallelism of that and then
we actually estimate pi
okay so we got the value of Phi up to
five it's again with this in not bad now
let's try to run this and run this in a
distributed manner
right same thing
we're going to run this in distributed
Manner and you can actually see now that
there are 10 different tasks
each of this is a different process now
because I'm running this on my laptop I
have 10 processors running each has a
paid ID but if I had clusters then this
would actually be running on a
particular cluster right so I have 10
tasks although you can see they're sort
of all running asynchronously they've
been scheduled
and then it took about what 42
millisecond compared to what it took me
for the serial one so you can see the
difference between you know running
something seriously and running in
parallel in a very simple manner right
all you had to do was just decorate your
your classes or your functions and you
would actually do that
so just to recap you know you can
actually use these array raid decorators
to be able to take any of your functions
that you have and then convert that into
a distributed setting
now let's do another example where
this is something that you actually
might do which is very common in in
doing deep learning where you actually
have all these images that that you are
going to transform them before you
actually give you the training you know
you might scale the image you might do
some segmentation you might do some
masking you might resize the image you
might flip it so what I'm trying to show
over here is that you can actually do
all these Transformations on the image
that you have and you can use Ray to
just distribute those Transformations
and when you get the Transformations now
you can actually do training with that
and you can do that very easily give me
the right task so what I have we have
some important utils that that I have
and I'm going to take all these images
that I have
which are large images and I'm going to
create them into batches but for for
brevity I've just scaled down the
batches to be 28 40 60 and 80.
and for the time I'm not going to run
those things I already ran it so what
I'm going to show you is walk through
the code that this particular array
function all it does is transforms the
image and the transformation does a
couple of things the symmetric render
measures multiplication it flips the
particular image it it scales it to to a
particular size and then there's some
other torsion multiplication this will
be something that you will actually do
for your for your images then you can
actually do that in parallel and then
return the value and then we'll try to
see what those what those images look
like after they've been transformed
so if I run this serially
this is my code that just downloads the
stuff and I'm going to look at the image
and that's what the images actually look
like
random display and I'm going to go ahead
and I hate this
so if I run this serial you can actually
see that the first batch took about 13
13 seconds
the second one 28 the third one was 48
and the last one was 60 and if I rent
that in distributed manner the only
thing I did between between the serial
and distributor was I took the images
and I put them in the object store
right I put the images I put them in the
object store and then I can just get
those images from the object store right
now that's where the object store comes
into play so this particular Object
Store now actually this is the one note
so I actually have one object store and
then I have all these workers running
will actually fetch that particular
value
so this is what I'm doing I'm taking all
these images and I'm putting in an
object store and notice that what's
actually returned is just a list right
I've just returned the particular list
of the object references and this is
sort of an encoded data that tells me
where the object store are you know what
machine is running on you don't have to
worry about that this is this you know
32 byte encoded string that that's meant
for internally reference
and when I run that in a distributed
manner you can actually see the time
difference between five seconds nine
seconds 11 seconds
and then I do a plot and you can see
when I do a plot you can actually see
the huge difference between how we
actually took to do that and all those
Transformations were done in parallel
any questions
you have all that code you can actually
run it
okay we've got half an hour
okay let's go to the second one
nodes
so Ray comes with this built-in
autoscaler right and what happens is
that let's say you have 10 let's say you
have fine nodes and you hear 20 tasks
who asks the question I yeah and you
have 20 tasks you actually do now all
the tasks have been have been filled in
and now you're actually scheduling more
talents what the auto scaler will do is
it'll actually start a particular node
two or three nodes based on your need
and it will inform you'll register those
with the GCS and then GC will broadcast
that to to the raillet and now you
actually have two node edit and the
queue that that was pending now is
actually scheduled so yes you can
actually do auto scaling that comes
comes comes with the open source version
of Ray so yeah there is an auto scoring
Auto scaling over here we don't Auto
scale because you know you're running on
your laptop but if you're running on
let's say AWS when you actually create
your clustered idml you can actually say
how frequent I want the auto scaling so
do I actually want to wait for one
minute or two minutes before I say go
ahead and do that and you can you can do
it up to and how many so
yeah you can say maximum number
obviously you know there's a physical
limit of how much money you're going to
pay but in certain cases yes you know
you might create a 10 node cluster and
you want five extra nodes to be added we
should be the same images that you
actually create in your cluster.gml so
whether it's whether it's a Docker image
for for your ec2 instance or it's on on
Azure I mean on Azure or even on gcp
yeah so Auto scaling is part and parcel
of the open source is the function of
the underlying infrastructure as code or
is it specific to like for example
public cloud or how do you implement
that well so if you're running on say
AWS and when you're doing Auto School we
we already have the image of that that
you actually created and we just use
that particular image to to to
raise the auto scale arrays is is
telling the aw cloud provider go ahead
and create those instances so the auto
scaler is is the one that's actually
written Ray the underlying uh launching
and the provision is actually depending
on a cloud provider right so it's using
the the rest apis they go ahead and
create this particular image right
because it knows already what your
images are
node or is it spelling of a load via
kubernetes for example and if you're
running on kubernetes corpuscp yes it
will do that if you're running on edible
yes it's going to spin up in ec2
instance with the same number of nodes
that you actually have right so let's
say this has eight workers and I have
Auto scalar you'll actually
create a replica of that right which is
homogeneous or heterogeneous
I mean you can't change the
configuration on the slide but but this
is going to be the same thing
okay so I at this particular exercise
all it actually shows is how you can
actually use memory Object Store to be
able to take advantage of of these in
your tasks and your your actors and so
we already talked about it and what I'm
going to show you over here is what am I
doing in terms of doing the same thing I
have some I have some massive numpy
array
and I want to transform those before I
actually do anything with that so we
actually use the object store to be able
to actually do that and that helps quite
a bit
okay so let's go through the code over
here
I know this is a lot of code but when
you actually have the Hands-On exercise
you actually get the feel of what it is
um so bear with me
so my remote Object Store I'm actually
creating
um
this particular random tensors that all
it does is just create tenses of random
value
and then returns those random value and
then transform is is a remote routine
that actually takes that and then
creates that and the transform can do
any one of these things so I do all this
massive transformation actually
happening in parallel
so we create a transform we put it in
the object store and then we finally
return the list
as comprehension objects so these are
the lists these actually now when we do
a rate output with all these different
tensors or different tensor sizes I get
an object reference
right here and this is the object
reference that I'm going to send it to
my actor or to my task to do that and
then when I send those object reference
wherever task is actually scheduled
you'll try to do a rate.get on it
because it'll implicitly say okay you
send me a reference I'm going to
dereference it and I'll get the value
and I'll work with that so you can see
what's actually been returned over here
is a list of object references
so if I just give you an idea of what it
means so I just take the first value of
object I do a while reference on it I do
a get of it and I get the value of the
tensor you're going to get this what the
value of tensor looks like so that's
what I mean by doing rate get and Ray
put
okay
so let's transform the object store in
that so here
in my comprehension list I've taken
the entire list I'm taking one object
reference at a time I'm sending this
particular function and once it's
transformed it's actually returned me a
transform version of the object
reference and this is this is the new
object reference and one thing to note
that these object records are immutable
right so once you do a put on that
particular Object Store you can't change
you have to create something else
they're immutable so you can't change
that in place you have to get a new one
to do that
and when I get the values back you can
actually see these transforms have
actually been been already transformed
and all that happened actually in
parallel using ray.get and rate output
any questions over here about object
references
simple concept A lot of things actually
happen behind the scenes that you don't
have to worry about
okay one thing one thing to note about
object reference is you can actually
pass them by value
we can pass them by reference and
depending on on your scenario
when when you want to use one or the
other
okay so here we're going to create a
very simple
um function called
given a particular argument just Echo
tell me what it is right
and I'm going to create some values over
here so we'll just go ahead and
so once I do pass by value and when I
pass by value I'm just sending in the
actual value
and since this is Echo dot remote it
always returns you some object reference
now we are not returning a value it's
just a null value but the function
builds Always written in object
reference
so now we're going to go ahead and send
an object reference and see what
actually happens over here
so let's do this
what happened to my thingy
let me just run all this to the end so
we actually have an idea
so I hope your reference is actually
great because you can actually things
pass by value and pass by reference and
over here I'm actually creating this
particular list and I'm passing by value
so when I do that
why is it not running
so you can see the argument return which
is 25.
even though I sent it I sent the value
by value it's just going to return 25.
on the other end if I just send the
object reference it's going to do the
same thing
it's going to dereference that and then
print the value right
if I pass by reference and why would you
want to actually pass by reference it's
possible that you actually don't need
the value right away you need some value
down the stream that you're actually
passing on so if you want to pass
something by reference what you do is
you put that into a dictionary you put
that in a list so the receiving function
would know that okay this is by
reference I'm not going to dereference
it by default you know it's going to
dereference it so if I send this
particular value over here
you can actually see that that it did
not de-reference it
it just took the it just print out the
value of the reference itself and I
could just keep on passing the reference
down the stream elsewhere where the
value is actually needed then I can
actually do a radar get so this is sort
of a good way to to manage those
and if I do the echo of this again
same thing happen
now I think the question is well what
happened if you have a long-running
tasks right how long do you actually do
a radar get how long do you actually
wait for it you have to have some sort
of an idea that I'm going to time out at
certain times because if you have a
large functions that block
for any particular reason right you want
to start debugging the thing you know
what happens then so I have a long
running task and I'm just going to go
ahead create this function and return
the answer to the universe
and I'm going to time this function and
what I'm doing over here is I'm going to
do a ray.get but I'm going to put a
Timeout on it right and the timeout is
going to be you know six seconds and I
have I'm sleeping for 10. so obviously
I've got an exception at one point right
so let's do this
if I run this
it's going to block for about six
seconds and then I'm going to an
exception
because I timed out so this sort of good
value good way to say if if your radar
gate is taking too long you can actually
put a put a call around it
the other ways
which are we
which are more programmatic way to do
those things if let's say you actually
have a large list of object references
and each of those lists might take a
different time what you can do is you
can do a radar weight on that particular
list and tell you how return me the
numbers that actually already been
finished
so what you can do is you can actually
put in the while loops and saying go
ahead and you know go ahead and iterate
over this and then just return me the
ones that actually have finished so what
you get is the tool list once they have
actually finished and once they're still
pending and you just iterate all that
right so that's sort of one way to say
if you have a large object reference
list and each of them have different uh
different times to materialize you can
actually use this particular radar get
to do that
any questions
yeah foreign
that you can no longer just call it as a
regular function no you know once you
put that remote you we actually
serialize it and and send it to send it
to the remote uh node to actually do
that if you now you can't call it you'll
actually get a syntax error
when you when you do put the
immutable what if you put a mutable
python object into one of those values I
put in a list can I call end on it later
well if you if you do a put
then that python list is going to be
emittable what you can do is you can do
a get
you get a copy of that make a copy of it
do your transformation that you put
again
because
rare objects are immutable that's the
whole reason what you want otherwise
you're going to run the work because
they can be passed over and how do you
actually maintain the mutation across
across across different clusters of your
passing
so the way people actually change
mutations is is they will get a copy of
that particular you know they're trying
for example I did I put all my images in
there I did the Transformations over
there and then once I'm done with those
transformation I do a re put again
and then now I actually have a new list
because every time you put you're
actually going to get a new reference to
it
right the old reference is not going to
be changed
this is something very similar to rdds
you know when you have those sort of
immutable objects and when you make a
transformation the original object is
not changed every time you do an action
it will do that and this is one reason
why you can actually recreate those
things so this is actually good for us
to do failover so let's say you're
actually doing something and something
actually fails over so we can actually
recreate all the objects that you
actually put in the store that the state
where it was before if you start
changing those things then we don't
actually have have that
just reuse or reference counting or some
other method so that when Once uh once
one of those objects that's in the
stores yes
good question the question is does Ray
actually use really we actually have a
distributed reference counting that that
keeps track of which objects have been
created by who and how long uh how many
pointers are are are pointing to that
and when that when comes down to zero
which is very simple some very similar
Technique we remove those objects
the primary copy will remain over there
till till the ray task is is finished
and then we just if there's no
references we just delete the primary
copy so there's a difference in primary
copy and secondary copy copy the primary
copy is the one that the object that the
original creator of the function
actually created that so if it's a
driver that created that or a particular
node that actually created that owns the
primary copy and subsequently everything
is actually a secondary copy
single node and the secondary copy is uh
like if you have
on eight on one node right second in
copy the second copy is on demand right
so if there's there's a primary copy
sitting on node a and there is a there's
a function that was that was the two
which you actually sent the reference is
it's somehow scheduled on node B and it
needs that it's going to de-reference it
as I don't even my rail it can be where
it is and it will it will relay it will
actually copy that
so those two threads the two threads
that I have relate and Object Store
thread those are responsible for doing
all that
and that's sort of you know the beauty
of that you actually don't have to think
too much about about that you just do
Ray get and Ray pudding and do that
obviously you have to worry about you
know how big are the references that you
can do radar weight and all that
so these are sort of primitive functions
right that sort of give you the power to
do that now you know as as you take
other classes that we actually teach
where now you can you don't need to
worry about doing your rate get and
where you put all of a runtime libraries
just take care of that for you
okay I'm going to skip that for the um
uh for brevity I wanted to introduce you
to Ray actors
so as I said earlier the way reactors
work is that when you actually create an
instance of array actor
the reactant takes over the entire
worker node
it it it's sort of scheduled on that
particular word and it's dedicated to it
so let's say you're eight eight eight
cores and you have eight workers running
and I create an instance of a reactor
and somebody gets scheduled in node a
it's going to take over that particular
worker and now their worker becomes an
actor
right and any calls any method instances
that your reference actually has are
going to be scheduled on that they'll be
they'll descend to that particular
reactor
it's a consumable that you have other
actors running on the same code I mean
on the same note but they'll be running
on a different process
so that's how it actually works and the
way it actually works is the ray ledge
says okay I have this particular actor
and it needs four CPUs I don't have it
who has it you know it's going to send a
broadcast we're called broadcasting list
and once it actually gets a list it will
know that okay I'm just going to
schedule this over here and then let
array that particular array lad take
care of it and any calls after that will
just be scheduled on that so that's how
it actually sort of at a high level the
the the scheduling actually works for
reactor and then once you actually have
the reactor now whatever the driver code
that you have or whatever python
application that when they actually
invoke that we just make a grpc call and
and send the data and it will get
executed on that
all the methods that are on that
particular actor if you invoke them in a
particular manner they'll be executed in
a Serial manner there are ways you can
do asyncs if you define a method async
the actor becomes async asynchronously
so if you didn't want to serialize the
invocation method you just wanted them
to execute asynchronously you can do
that asynchronously and we Implement
async Loop underneath the actor that
does that
okay
okay I ran this already so I'm not going
to run through this because I think we
only have like 10 minutes left
so what's the first problem that we
actually might want to do with reactors
um
this is a good use case let's say you're
doing telemetry
right you want to find out you create a
particular package and you want to find
out who's actually using that particular
package this is a very common problem
that we actually use when you go to
Telemetry when you uh when you release a
new open source code and you want to
find out you know how people are using
it what library is actually using this
is not a good way to find out what
methods are being actually used for my
particular actor so in this particular
use case I'm creating a couple of actors
that actually have and I'm invoked in
those particular methods and based on
that method
um you know they'll be scheduled on
they'll be sent to either actor one or
actor two and I keep a counter of who
actually invoked me and how many times
they were invoked
so this is sort of a diagram of what
what this particular Ray code is
executing on the driver or on my python
script and then these are the actors
that is talking to and I'm keeping
keeping State Remember actors are the
way that you can actually keep state of
it and that's the important bit
so I'm just creating a class over here
um Base Class that actually has some
Constructor arguments a method a
dictionary that I keep track of the
method name that I actually use and I
keep a count of it and then this My
Method could be any generic method I'm
doing and I'm I'm sending in some key
value arguments and I might do something
with the key value arguments right and
then some method functions will get get
those particular method and then get the
name so those are sort of Base clause
and I'm going to inherit this class and
I'll decorate that with the radar remote
and I'll Implement my my do something
method now to do something method could
be something easier something relevant
to you have the command line arguments
in here you might want to put in the
database or you might write to a
particular file or you might do
something with it so that's your radar
method that we have and then after that
you want to update that particular
countries that this method was actually
called with this particular arguments so
you kind of have a way of of collecting
Telemetry data
and same thing with the second class I
actually do the same thing over here
and I'm going to create two instances of
that I create the instance one I call it
my extra one and second instance actor
two
and in this particular logic over here I
just have some some variables that say
that I have a list of vector 1 and X2 I
give I assign them with with with the
instances of those
and I'm just going to have a little for
Loop that I randomly choose between
those two actors and I call those you
know in in in in a list and I'm saying
well with the uh with if if my method is
one then I'm just going to go ahead and
store my values in the store database if
it's if it's actor 2 then I'm going to
call and put it somewhere else in a key
value store and return it
and when I do that
um you know I get my my accounts and
then finally I can do this ray.get to
see what was the end result of those
calls very easy simple case but you can
see that actually maintaining state
right and you can men's state for a lot
of things and reactors are very
primarily used in over array libraries
because if you look at how we've got a
train works and how Ray tune works all
these actually create actors and these
actors are sort of managing state of a
hyper permanent tuning of the results so
if you're doing a fine tuning actually
find out what your metric values are so
all those are are created and they talk
to each other and so that is a crucial
part of our Ray air libraries to do that
and I can actually look at my dashboard
to see
what these look like
now one of the things about the reason
you can't see the metrics over here
because in the open source version you
actually install have to install grafana
and Prometheus to be able to for us to
actually put all those metrics but if
you're using the managed version of any
scale you get all that particular free
so it's not that you don't get it all
you do if I install grafana and
Prometheus over here and then tell the
array to say this is my local version of
that go ahead and put the metrics and
you'll be able to actually see all the
metrics
and there's all my actress that that Ren
some of them are dead already
so that was an example of
um
of how we actually use reactor
the other thing I wanted to show is that
is that how you can actually use the
same thing that we actually use in our
first example but we're going to use
reactor and the way you're going to use
reactor is that we're going to use
reactor that keeps progress of the pi as
it been Computing by the tasks so in one
way we actually did a stateful way where
every task was actually created and just
returned the point over here we're going
to have the same thing but we're going
to have reactor that keeps track of
where how far we actually have gone in
maintaining the um the ray actor
so I'm going to create a closer vehicle
progress bar and all this actually doing
is is keeping track of all the task
ideas that I have
along with
the number of samples that actually have
completed for me they're able to create
a progress report and I have some
function calls that says go ahead and
get the progress of that and the way I
completely progress is total number of
tasks and how many have been computed so
I get some sort of a percentage
and then we Define our task which was no
different from our previous version in
in Ray tasks but I'm just make that as a
remote task
I Define all the different variables
that actually have which is pretty much
the same thing and I won't have the
frequency at every one millionth of the
data point tell me you know give me the
percentage of where we are
so that's sort of maintaining the state
I go ahead and create this particular
actor instance
and then using
this particular comprehension list I go
ahead and check I re yeah raising this I
just I just this loop I just go ahead
and create the task and I call my
prosing actor
and I just do a get on this and you can
actually see it's actually return me the
progress as we actually go along
and the way it's actually doing is that
this particular here Ray got progress
that remote is the one that's that's
that's keeping the state of that and the
ray tasks are the one which actually
getting a value or a reference to the
progress actor and I remember I'm
sending it I'm sending in the handle to
the actor over here
so the ray task can actually update
where I am so if you look at the rate
tasks over here
rate taxes gets a handle
to the actor and now it's actually once
it's actually done the computation it's
going to send a message to the reactor
using this particular call
progress acted that report the progress
for that particular task ID
right
so these tasks are executing in a
parallel manner but they have a
reference to one actor that's keeping
progress of that
simple idea but you know these are the
things you can actually do
and then we just computed compute that
so what we actually shown over here
there are two ways you can use actors
actors are stateful entities that you
can actually keep track of that you can
schedule them on any particular red
cluster you can assign them resources
that you actually want I want to use one
CPU only one you use GPU you can send
actors as arguments to other actors you
can send arguments actors as arguments
as a tasks and the tasks can send
messages to that right
and you can have multiple actors running
and I think in the next one we'll
actually show that I have three minutes
I can't go over okay
I can't hold these people that kept you
half of them are going to sleep
okay
um I wish we had more time because
there's so much good stuff over here I
wanted to share with you guys
um
so this is this is a very design pattern
that that's very popular in our real
libraries which is called a tree of
actors and actress is is fundamental to
to to to some of the array
implementation across all the libraries
whether you're using tune train remote
reinforcement learning array so and the
idea over here is that I have a driver
or my python script that's going to
create a number of supervisor actor and
each supervisor actually has a bunch of
actors that actually creates and then
and these actors now communicate with
you at the keeping State and then
finally the supervisor can actually
query the actor where am I and this is
no different let's say you're doing
let's say you're doing hyper parameter
tuning right you actually create a
trainer and train actually has a tuner
it creates all this particular task each
task has to report after a particular
trial what was the loss you know what
was my learning rate all that metric and
those can be actually kept state in each
of these each of these individual actors
and can send me send me back and can be
reported
so this is a very common design pattern
used exclusively and entirely in all of
the libraries and you can use that as
well hyper parameter tune uses that rare
Gene user and the idea is is for this
particular example we are doing same
data different functions so what I'm
doing is I have three different actors
that will train XT boost that will train
linear regression and decision tree and
with with the same data and then give
you the results of what was the best
particular library that was used
can I do that in one minute
you can do in one minute okay good I ran
it before
all right so I did so this is about I'm
training this data on over California
not not Seattle Housing database so I
have I have this particular data I'm
going to create a generic class
Factory that take that allows me to use
three different algorithms random Forest
linear regression and and decision tree
okay
I'm going to create an instance of a
supervisor
my supervisor actually creates three
different actors and now what I have is
and then I'm just going to get the
results of this and then find out the
results of of how they actually did
so I created a supervisor
I launch each and every actor each and
every actor now is running independently
one is doing xgboost training one is
doing linear regression the other one
using decision tree right they're using
the same data California Housing said
but they're running in parallel and
they're keeping State and they're
communicating with the supervisor so
here we actually see these are three of
those running so I've got XC boost that
ran I have decision tree somewhere down
the road yeah I have
a random for us and I have a decision to
reactor all of this are running in
parallel
and I just have a loop that that sort of
keeps state of of where it is when I'm
done with all of those things I get out
the loop and I and I get the sorted
value of all the results so what the
results are being returned by each and
every algorithm is the MSA and I want to
get the best MSC that I actually have
and so I run them and you can see that
the results are I've used 150 estimators
use you know these are the hyper
parameter initial tunes that actually
used and I get the mscs for all of them
and if you look at the dashboard you
actually see all those running in
parallel
damn I did it in one minute
this would have taken longer though but
the fun part is that you guys get to do
it I don't have to do it right but you
know unfortunately I had I I don't have
enough time but thank you for coming uh
and you have this with you
thank you